[Musik]
nein
ja
[Musik]
wie viel zählt ein einzelnes
menschenleben sind wir bereit dafür viel
zu geben auch wenn es viel kostet die
medizin rettet leben
doch sie hat ihren preis und stellt die
gesellschaft vor die drängende frage wie
lange können wir uns das noch leisten
[Musik]
wir sind auf der intensivstation im
universitätsspital in zürich ein 50
jähriger mann mit einem schweren schädel
hirn trauma wird angeliefert
wir konnten beharrten weiter abgefallen
bis 60 und dann bei um die 60 geblieben
für maximal fünf minuten
wir haben uns dann schieben zu
intubieren haben das dann gemacht
problemlos information
wie dann die maschine genommen der 50
jährige patient ist nicht ansprechbar
das problem ist einer der kollegen im
ausland ansässige ort kontakt mansory -
ohne dass er viel aber nicht eilig hat
wie ich das ehrwürdiger und das macht
die ganze situation schwierig
zentrale ski im moment mal das könnte
nur trauriges zeichen
die intensivstation gilt innerhalb eines
spitals als die kostenintensivste
der personelle aufwand ist enorm die
therapien sind aufwendig das ziel ist
klar
leben retten
[Musik]
eintrag auf eine intensivstation kostet
im schnitt 4000 franken
[Musik]
bei diesen patienten muss das ärzte team
einen neuen venen katheter setzen
es ist ein 88-jähriger mann schickt wo
er war am geburtstagsfest seines sohnes
als er einen plötzlichen herzstillstand
erlitt er wurde reanimiert seit zwei
tagen ist er auf der intensivstation
überhaupt nicht kann man sollte nimmt
der kreislauf stillstand möglichen
schauten überhaupt nicht aber das weite
meer rezession und locker und branche
mehrere patienten erlaubt vom altertum
dass hundekot beschluss eigentlich dann
doch nach gurken sind und die chance
muss man auch das ehepaar nora ist auf
der intensivstation
die beiden sind frisch operiert und
kämpfen für ein gemeinsames leben
sie haben zwei mädchen zwillinge und
einen juli hat indirekt
[Musik]
die 38 jährige anita laurent hatte krebs
mit metastasen und brauchte dringend
eine neue liebe ihr mann kam als spender
in frage und hat ihr darum einen teil
von seiner gespendet
seine leber wird sich wieder erholen und
bei ihr sollte diese eine teil lieber
zum leben reichen
[Musik]
dass ich eine option gesehen hat was man
daraus machen das ja
inzwischen aber ist gut so gut wenn man
uns möglich
alfred lorang ist bereits stabil und
kann auf eine andere station verlegt
werden
[Musik]
anita borer hingegen muss nochmals in
den operationsraum sie ist von der
transplantation noch sehr geschwächt
muss aber zwingend ein zweites mal
operiert werden
sie hat ein leck bei der galle wenn
dieses nicht geschlossen werden kann
droht dass sie die transplantierte lebe
verliert
[Musik]
die behandelnde ärztin der
intensivstation weiß die situation ist
kritisch und das leben der jungen frau
gefährdet
ich gehe jetzt dort hinein in den
operationssaal ich werde das betrachten
mit den chirurgen und ich hoffe dass wir
dann aufschluss bekommen wie es aussieht
[Musik]
es wäre auch nicht gut wenn es nicht so
wäre denke ich ja aber muss die gewisse
distanz haben weil sonst würde es
einfach kaputt mache ich glaube es wäre
auch nicht gut
sonst kann man das nicht jahrelang
machen das operationsteam ist gefordert
es muss die öffnung zwischen galle und
leber schließen und damit verhindern
dass weiterhin flüssigkeit in den
bauchraum fließt das wird nicht einfach
sein
beim 88 jährigen fiktiv wurde der venen
katheter neu gelegt nun sitzt er wichtig
immer noch kämpft er mit der atmung
der aufwand ist groß hat gefragt lohnt
sich das das grund durfte prozent
aber einfach sagen 50000 franken sind
viel bitterkeit therapie obwohl mit
chance hat dass der pc anschluss
eigentlich mit guter qualität
alte menschen sollen keine teuren
therapien mehr bekommen sagt eine
mehrheit der schweizer bevölkerung in
einer repräsentativen umfrage im jahr
2017 wenn ein tag auf der
intensivstation etwa 4000 franken kostet
ist fiktiv nun aus sicht der
gesellschaft einen tollen fall
[Musik]
wir sind auf der akutgeriatrie im
zürcher waidspital eine abteilung
ausschließlich für betagte menschen
das spiel blieb
im verlaufe der user kann ich mir vom
usc extreme er im augenblick schon heute
gibt es politische vorstöße die fordern
keine herzschrittmacher mehr für
hochbetagte und auch keine hüft und
knieprothesen die 84-jährige hatte
gallensteine musste operiert werden
seither erholt sich nur langsam seit
zwei monaten ist sie im spital
sie braucht immer noch infusionen vorher
war
aber jetzt heißt es krebs besucher
überhaupt auf die idee zum seite die
alte menschen so viel prunk
das problem ist dass man jedes jahr über
gesundheitszustand und das wetter morgen
die prämie wieder rufen könnten da die
papiere nirgendwo zu finden
dort setzte bundesrat börse hat setzt
gemacht dass man bitte ambulant tarif
eingriff gemacht hat aber man hat dann
immer
der fokus auf ein teil davon und da
sieht wurden 40 mit sich bringt die
benutzung ist kalkül ihnen und verdrehte
ist sehr unbefriedigend aus was man
gemacht hat und sich immer wieder das
gespann für die idee von der aktionäre
auf der tischplatte das heißt also
aktionäre geist letztlich dürfte sie
muss man sich medizinisch sinnvolle
leistungen meiner patienten nehmen
anbieter bestimmte jahrgang hat
[Musik]
die rationierung ist hierzulande noch
kein thema in anderen ländern in england
beispielsweise ist sie bereits realität
unser problem sei ein anderes sagt der
onkologe thomas cerny zu viele wollen
heute mit kranken menschen geld
verdienen
wir sind total stimme wie mehr
katalysieren dann also immer die
ökonomie und produkt und gewinn in der
medizin offenbart als erfolgsmodell so
viel habt wohne werde
und überall bewertungstechnisch wird das
ausgereizt
wer krank ist rechnet anders das
überleben zählt nicht wie viel es kostet
wir sind mit dem fünfjährigen alex auf
dem weg ins kinderspital zürich
seit zwei jahren fährt seine mutter mit
ihm regelmäßig dieser strecke alex hat
leukämie
sie gilt bei ihm als nicht heilbar
sie schritt für schritt jetzt
[Musik]
fluggäste
sie schaut wie immer mehr sind das nicht
entscheiden alex und sie treffe dort
entscheide wie immer mieter können und
was man machen
man probiert was machen
wieder steht eine untersuchung im
kinderspital an
bei alex wurde bereits alles medizinisch
mögliche versucht er hat mehrere
chemotherapien hinter sich +2
knochenmarktransplantationen die
krebszellen sind bei ihm immer wieder
zurückgekehrt momentan geht es ihm gut
er hat eine antikörpertherapie die in
stabil hält
bei alex wird dieses mal eine
knochenmark funktion gemacht
sie soll zeigen wie hoch der anteil an
leukämie zellen ist und ob allenfalls
eine neue therapie infrage kommt etwas
könnte ihn vielleicht noch heilen
eine so genannte car to sell therapie
ein ganz neues verfahren das jedoch eine
halbe million franken kostet und von
novartis erst in den usa angeboten wird
und könntest dir der halbmillionenstadt
bringen
er hetzt sicher schon mal den platz
fotos machen habe aber millionen
es ist schön dass sie genug kosten von
einer ganze therapien tagesstätte zu
ich meine ein bussard überflügelte
unterkunft um eine halbe million stellen
eine schwierige situation auch für den
behandelnden arzt hier der kleine alex
die man unbedingt helfen möchte dort die
teuren medikamente verordnet sie so viel
harmonie de ski aber wenn man dann
plötzlich ältere nicht mehr in den golf
als halt doch darum alles mögliche zu
unternehmen um
resona heilig vielleicht doch noch ein
herz für ihre sondern die mannschaft
natürlich immer sofort die hoffnung und
überhaupt wenn es vater ruft
die cortisol therapie steht für eine
ganz neue ära in der medizin
es ist ein biochemisches verfahren im
körper werden zellen entnommen im labor
manipuliert und danach als antikörper
wieder den blutkreislauf zugeführt dort
sollen sie die krebszellen direkt
zerstören
für die pharma branche ein neues
lukratives feld ein millionengeschäft
mir völlig überrascht sie unter viel von
jener kollege sie völlig überrascht dass
da plötzlich cellular die therapie vor
der pharmafirmen gemacht werden weil
entwickelt worden die sie dort nicht
mehr hätte dort offenbar eine sache
patentieren
da damit monopolistische das mandat
mcqueen hamacher und das darf nicht sie
der basler pharmakonzern novartis hat
erst für die usa eine zulassung
doch die ksl therapie soll bald auch in
der schweiz erhältlich sein
ob sie hier auch eine halbe million
kosten wird novartis wollte vor der
kamera keine stellung nehmen und ließ
uns per e-mail wissen man setze sich für
eine innovative preisbildung 1
wenn das herz der geburt macht geteilt
werden günstiger das soll mir selber
machen da muss man natürlich der
entschlossen einfach für sich behalten
hätte nach der therapie selber den preis
und das ganze ist ja nicht so dass jetzt
die 450 musik sozusagen behandelt aber
dass ich nur die manipulation die
beamten kosten normal 100 user oder
sogar mehrere hundert musik wurde zu
haben
und bis geht es nach einer pause
allerdings ganze und denis stapel
automatisch den und natürlich jetzt wird
auch ein aufwand rom abgeholt werden
aber da der mini person 450 dass ich
denke du sie kranke wittlich
wenn die karte zelltherapie in der
schweiz zugelassen wird heißt das für
betroffene die kosten werden dann von
der grundversicherung der krankenkasse
übernommen
aber alex bleibt nicht die zeit darauf
zu warten sich sehr schwierig also ja du
bist du machtlos oder noch ausständige
dankbar für spenden ruhe vor dem
lokschuppen das ist natürlich könnte ich
schaute und du war ich mir lange als
lange zelt oder das ist ja das macht
dann natürlich psychisch kaputt alles
mitgenommen was willst du bist und du
faschist
es ist nicht erreichbar oder dubai
schaut dass sie bereits hinter sich
es ist auf rang fünf erreichen macht man
nicht tut man nicht alles über den hof
berühren oder nur zumeist ringt die
möglichkeit gehe oder um noch eine rolle
natürlich dreht sich alles nur noch um
krankheit und tod nicht das ist gold
kommt ja
die operation bei anita laurent hat
knapp drei stunden gedauert
sie hat sie gut überstanden es ist gut
gegangen
ich bin zufrieden ich bin erleichtert
über den befund den wir jetzt haben
das ist für diesen moment ist mal
[Musik]
gut für mich so die ärztin kann nun auch
den ehemann informieren
[Musik]
er der seine frau eine halbe liebe
gespendet hat wusste dass sie bei der
operation auch steigern könnten wir sind
noch nicht ganz über den berg aber
[Musik]
wieder hoffen sie beide in den nächsten
wochen wird sich zeigen ob an italo ross
körper die leber ihres mannes
akzeptieren wird
dieses eine leben zu retten kostet viel
geld
solche leistungen übernimmt die
grundversicherung der krankenkasse wenn
man die transplantation nicht hätte
machen können wäre die patienten nach
einer zeit gestorben
das ist irre
diese gepackt hat der 88 jährige victor
lerch ist bereits vier tage auf der
intensivstation
er hat immer noch atemprobleme ist aber
ansprechbar
wir treffen seinen sohn bei ihm er war
es der sagte bei seinem vater müsse
alles medizinisch mögliche gemacht
werden zum innehalten
er hat freude am leben wie tesla begrüße
das hamra damit schon vorher miteinander
abgesprochen
in zenica für das doch statt in ihrem
vater soll bei handwerk davon aus dass
es relativ zürich das nicht genau das
wird wochen hielt dutzend 2030 franken
kosten
in der intensiv station ist das völlig
normal weiß nicht genau was hat mein
gott das ist ja ball an krankenkassen
gezahlt und
danke sind die kosten einfach im inneren
im land wie der schweiz wo man human und
zivilisiert denkt und handelt einfach
etwas so wenige menschen überleben eine
reanimation nach einem herzstillstand
nur gerade einer von zehn 78 hätte
unsere sei ja wie sie sagt sehr viel
über sechs jahren mit 88 es die könnten
ja sowohl das seit dem 1
das sieht companies das alte wappen
höchste qualität
aktuell wird wohl schon bald auf eine
andere station verlegt werden können
wer spitalaufenthalt wird mutmaßlich
etwa 40 bis 50 tausend franken kosten
auch diese leistung wird von der
grundversicherung der krankenkasse
übernommen
ein betrag fest setzte die wehr dass man
erzählerin patient das ist wahnsinnig
schwierig centers primär medizinisch
entscheiden ob man den teil der wahlzeit
du willst dass maximal so und so viel
investieren und dann und stellte prozent
sowie zimmer zum glück noch nie
aber es muss es sinnvoll die therapie
sie jetzt muss ein prozess bringen kann
man das sogar ins leere
also habe ich immer garantieren
medizinisches fach und ihr gibt es kann
immer etwas passieren dass er schlecht
riecht es endlich geklappt hat gibt aber
als andere dass der prozess um rund 1000
auf und denkt hat und wo er seine
prozente die chance
unser gesundheitssystem baut auf dem
prinzip der solidarität die bedürftigen
werden von denen getragen die gesund
sind
im wissen darum dass es jeden treffen
könnte
[Musik]
zurück ins spital zu den betagten noch
bekommen alle alles doch die zunehmende
überalterung 14 nicht unweigerlich dazu
dass wie rationieren müssen
als gesellschaft entscheiden muss man
politik darüber diskutieren dann muss
gesamtbevölkerung darüber diskutieren
sind die frage was gewicht man höre das
virus kann für gesundheitsleistungen
sprich die krankenkassenprämie und
fundstücken befinden uns sparen wichtig
und dafür in kauf dass etwas gewissen
mit den leistungen vorenthalten werden
und da muss jeder überlegen und was
meine großmutter andere hunger gilt denn
das griffige oder gilt das eigentlich
nur für anime anonym
die diskussion ist das laufen durch
meistens polonia ob die müssen mit
treten land sie das bei ihrer mutter
waren das mit 90 ps motorleistung
beschränkt werden sie zu ganz am schluss
[Musik]
schon heute sind die
krankenkassenprämien für viele nicht
mehr bezahlbar jeder fünfte in der
schweiz ist auf die prämienverbilligung
durch den staat angewiesen
das enorme medizinische angebot ist
schon heute eine finanzielle belastung
für unser gesundheitssystem wissen die
fachleute und es kommen immer noch
teurere errungenschaften dazu ich danke
dir heikel diskussion nach wie vor
miserabel system ist finanziert steht
einfach prämie
aber grundsätzlich ist das system
finanziert und führt nicht einfach zu
einer rationierung während wo kein geld
mehr war als eine hand qualität stehen
wo wir sagen stopp
jetzt haben wir neben finanzieren
letztlich zahle das einfach die
prämienzahler mit jeder jedes jahr mit
höheren prämien guido klaus zeigt uns
diese neue entwicklung an konkreten
zahlen
die ausgaben für medikamente sind in den
letzten vier jahren um eine milliarde
gestiegen das sei erst der anfang
prophezeit thomas cerny die ära der
teuren therapien habe erst begonnen
die dynamik von denen medikamente prise
ist gigantisch und die zeit maps und der
pass alter noch ranke aber mittlerweile
zeigt auch dass et gi antikörper und
neue entwicklungen die werden die
herzinsuffizienz ziel gesetzt die werden
ob im diabetes kombi klimatologie zum
teil sie sich schon gehört und wer ganz
einander die bradley h und so gesehen
werden
der höhere preis aber den sehr häufig
müssen zahlt werde und das nicht
rechtfertigen unter mir jetzt politisch
vorgang dass das gesundheitssystem mit
letzterer gilt
[Musik]
dass etwas getan werden muss wissen auch
die in bern seit jahren suchen sie nach
lösungen
ideen sind viele da aber durchsetzen
lässt sich nur wenig
ein problem das man so viel interesse
gruppe hören wo an der gesetzgebung und
an dem rahmen haken gleich zu prägen der
sich patienten die industrie dass sich
interessant und allianz permanenten
shepherd zum negatives wegfurt lösung
und hitze oder partikularinteressen man
versuche natürlich nützlich und bekommt
von der linie der ligue un findet
einfache lösungen warum findet er kaluza
möchte interesse so disparat
cdu-vertreter seloger dass ihre klientel
grüne ist vor der erste forfour man sich
davor der versicherte vor allem dass sie
schuld wieder und schwierig verschiedene
fragestellungen von chf 260 k 40 jahren
war es schwierig es wird schwierig sie
unsere politiker und politikerinnen
vertreten hier drinnen nicht nur ihre
partei
es hat wahre spitzenreiter unter ihnen
was die anzahl mandate in der
gesundheitsbranche betrifft ruth humbel
beispielsweise hat zwölf verwaltungsräte
in einer krankenkasse einer reha klinik
sitzt in einer pharma interessengruppe
und der ig seltene krankheiten wehrheim
ist bei der pro senectute spitex
patientenstelle dem spital club und
einer hornhautbank
und thomas de courten bei inter generika
swiss reha und einer fahrbahn
interessengruppe
die illusion dass politik all die
herausforderer
gesellschaft radtour findet sie
vergessen oder das parlament und politik
ist bürger bild vl sowie hängt die
briefe vogel mir händ alte brief
antworten oder keine antworten auf die
drängenden probleme auch hier auch im
eda vertritt interessen die einer
krankenkasse von ärzten eine reha und so
weiter es kann also dauern wie sie hier
eine lösung finden
derweil steigen die krankenkassenprämien
und damit der druck jetzt ein nachspiel
der fünfjährige alles lebt ein fast
normales leben
aber die antikörper therapie die er
bekommt wirkt nicht mehr lange
alex brüder benjamin und daniel der
kleine ist zweieinhalb jahre alt
genauso lange ist alex krank nun gibt es
wieder hoffnung für alex er kann
womöglich bei einer klinischen studie
für eine cortisol therapie mitmachen
für das chatten oder für amerika und
jetzt hatte man chance zum in studien
als rocker in europa der studie waren
rund 7 setzt das modell für die karten
alex braucht zwar unterstützung und
hilfe im alltag und er ist oft müde aber
dass er so schwer krank ist sieht man
ihm nicht an
das ist völlig doch das ist völlig dauer
ist ja ich weiß es nicht
meine therapie machen dann ist ethik ein
studienplatz ist kostenlos weil er der
forschung dient aber wenn die therapie
dann einmal eine halbe million oder noch
mehr kostet lässt sich das rechtfertigen
um ein leben zu retten
wann das theoretisch zur verfügung steht
und mir wisse dass hahn ist unsere
vielen fans zur essex bringen dann sind
verpflichtet irgendwie das zu
ermöglichen
ja ich denke es hätte druck wird auch so
groß wurde
ältere oder patienten das medikament
avandia schwierigkeiten schwanz
krankenkasse nicht zahlt wird es dann
wenn alles klappt wird alex bald nach
oben fahren und dort behandelt werden
sein vater wird ihn begleiten mich mit
gründung arbeitet in einem
schlachtbetrieb er kann unbezahlten
urlaub nehmen die ganze familie kann
nicht mit das können sie sich nicht
leisten
dank schimmel fördern
viel zeit bleibt nicht
alex muss bald nach ruhm können
es ist dieses quäntchen hoffnung für das
wohl die meisten von uns bereit sind
alles zu geben
[Musik]
wenn über ist das ihre chance
die alternative dazu denn wir die
menschen ist der versuchen aus startet
egal das heißt egal das fest wenn er zur
plane therapie ist oder therapie wo im
off label gut die daten dass es sinnvoll
ist und den opa willi geklärt denn das
ganz klar das wetter machen das wird ja
bloß als patient dass man ihr das auto
und die wird das jedem familie familie
genau gleich machen und die werden die
patienten nicht anders behandeln
anita loriot geht es ein bisschen besser
aber immer noch fließt gallenflüssigkeit
in den bauchraum
doch wahnsinnig geduld
verwunderung vermutlich muss sie noch
einmal operiert werden
präsentierte sich gar nicht
aber wohl so eine tortur setzte und so
viele strapazen hinter seine seite
ziehen
das ok schließen
[Musik]
anita lorang wird noch einige zeit auf
der intensivstation bleiben müssen
die prognose aber für den weiteren
verlauf ist nicht schlecht das macht was
das auch wirklich gut anders und wenn es
jetzt gut endet heißt das landeslabor
sich also liegt mit der transplantation
herr jeden tag gute prognose die
übergabe werde sehr gut akzeptiert woche
nicht so eine chance geben und
suppression dass man die ganze
komplikationen aber die nachricht dass
die menschen die tgs qualität liter
marathon-rennen damit ein stockwerk
weiter unten liegt ihr ehemann er kann
bald nach hause
er war insgesamt 13 tage hier aber wenn
ich dem web die nehmen bitte
krankenkasse melden
august das alles das gibt mir wohnt und
damals zum bedanken für alles was sie
gemacht wenn man den tour-sieg franken
bei mehr als 1000 franken im monat
musikers zahl ist straßen der stadt
wir haben nicht das ist gerechter nicht
wenn man kann die krankenkasse zahlen
und mehr braucht
den muss man froh sein
der 88 jährige victor lehrich ist seit
drei wochen in einer rehaklinik der cdu
komplett grund für den stufen vor die
ganze nichts passiert ist
den brauche ich denn das sein
fortsetzung
[Musik]
studien belegen jeder franken der in den
aufbau und die reha investiert wird
zahlt sich fünffach aus das heißt je
mehr am anfang investiert wird desto
günstiger kommt das langfristig
[Musik]
mas
auf die intensivstation sind in zwei
stunden fünf neue patienten gebracht
worden
[Musik]
es ist eine enorme dichte an
menschlichen schicksalen die wir hier am
treffen und bei den meisten geht es um
leben und tod
[Musik]
hamann intensivstation überhaupt noch
wirtschaftlich masbeck finde das
schwierig will man jetzt im oktober
sollen so viel sparen und
intensivstationen oder man sagt ja gott
dann bringe kein fahrzeug fertig sind
der römer sparer aber das kann ja nur
die patienten die mit wenders films und
ernst aus sämtliche wichtigen vorne
therapie also vereinbarkeit relativ
schwierig fast täglich werden auf der
intensivstation therapien eingestellt
therapie einstellen bedeutet hier den
patienten sterben lassen
in zieht maschinen aktiv stellt mit mit
unseren ärztlichen team zusammen oder ja
da arbeiten wir eng zusammen wir
sprechen uns im vorfeld wie wir vorgehen
und dann untersuchen den wildtieren dass
sie dem kino kennt sie steht rumänische
machen oder know me und noomi ich glaube
es ist auch dass man das über die jahre
einschätzen kann
ich glaube wir haben jetzt hier über
viele tage nahezu alles versucht was
irgendwie möglich war
wir haben alle register gezogen die man
irgendwie ziehen konnte und sind
irgendwo eine grenze gestoßen wo einfach
nichts mehr gegriffen hat wo hier mit
unseren sachen unseren möglichkeiten am
ende waren und ich glaube dann ist es
auch für uns etwas leichter los zu
lassen weil man dann sagen kann ist es
für den patienten vielleicht doch auch
eine erlösung und dann besser ja so
schwer wie sich das anhört aber ich
glaube es ist einfach mal eine erlösung
genau
der tod kommt heute meist nicht mehr
einfach so sondern erst wenn er
medizinisch zugelassen wird
sicher ist das große problem unter der
es auf der intensivstation
es ist nehmen die große frage kümmern
sondern die große frage macht sinn und
die meisten patienten sterben sind
einseitig war guter unter voller
therapie versterben das g2 aber die
meisten patienten können wir die
therapie stehe ich immer wenn wir
einfach so und therapiert hat und resi
untersuchungsresultate mit der
angehörige kräutern und schlussendlich
findet es macht keinen sinn oder special
vor ort kann sich der prozente zeitraum
anfallen können vorstellen
[Musik]
je mehr die medizin anbietet desto mehr
ist wohl jeder einzelne in der pflicht
sich zu fragen wie weit möchte ich gehen
wie viel ist mir mein leben wird
das camp der hoffnung nach reanimation
mit medizin kann nicht wirklich alles
retten und highlight jürgen stember man
ja nicht so dass mediziner die gz
sterblichkeit als wie viele denke das
gehört schlussendlich zum elementarer
grob musste vor der revolution die die
sterblichkeit der evolution wort
entwicklung und damit permanent sondern
wirklich die antike die medizin wo sie
denn wirklich bis vermutet
es geht einfach ein paar grundlegend ist
auch was auch eine corriente er siegte
mehrheit dominiert die wünsche und das
weite meer nieder
das ist zum beispiel das 6h nicht
verschwinden
und insofern gesichert wird nicht
einfach
die magische pille wo das problem lösen
habe mich immer wie man die krankheit zu
erträglichen krankheiten machen wie vor
krankheiten heilen
das wird in der stadt so fortsetze
[Musik]
noch einmal zurück ins spital unsere
frage machen wir heute so viel weil wir
uns so schwer tun mit dem loslassen mit
dem sterben
also man redet nur immer über das wasser
laufen die grenze überschritten
derartige weckten sie werde gegen damals
richtig machen werden unsterblich und
das hilft um sich mit der endlichkeit
auseinandersetzen ich glaube es braucht
prinzip ehemals es dafür andere größere
gesellschaft die hoffnung dass alex nach
oben kann und dort die ktc therapie
bekommt hat sich zerschlagen
seine leukämie hat sich so verändert
dass die therapie nichts mehr nützen
würde
die ursprüngliche therapie wo man hat
weder machen
ich habe jetzt nicht machen sich sie nie
leukämie zahle so verändert hat dass
eine durch das medikament aussprache
werdet ihr vorgänger hat jetzt ich mir
relativ anschlag hat nehme viele
möglichkeiten es gibt immer nur neue
medikament wo allenfalls könnten wirksam
sie bittere folgen für chemie steht mir
hoffentlich man konnte sehr wichtige
hoffnung dass sie sind alle schlachten
natürlich doch da sollte man mit seinem
roman wird die chance ich sage es
momentan komme ich mir vor dem
einschlafen fußballspiel der bilder foto
von mir bringt einfach dass ich den blöd
der fabrik aber so fühle ich mich
momentan menschen so viele chancen
und irgendwie haben wir sie einfach eine
können nutzer aus dem handy genutzt habe
mir als ziel einen können gleich um
handeln
noch einmal soll ein neues medikament
ausprobiert werden
die chance dass es wirken wird ist
jedoch sehr klein
wenn das dann nützt dann mir immer ruft
an harmonie und dann gehts nun begleitet
wurde dass möglichst kein schmerz muss
das möbelstück konnte was wäre gewesen
wenn alex de cádiz herr therapie früher
bekommen hätte solche gedanken belasten
nur noch mehr sagt seine mutter
vorwärts schauen und weiter hoffen das
bringe mir das problem ist halt einfach
du bist total am boden zerstört oder
zerstört wie man die augen stoppen wenn
das sich jetzt wieder zerplatzen kids
machen machen dass ich mit dem stromer
hat
[Musik]
das ehepaar lohra wir treffen die beiden
wieder im universitätsspital in zürich
ihre galle ist immer noch nicht dicht
darum ist anita lorang ganz gelb im
gesicht ihr bauch ist entzündet und
stößt die gespendete leber ihres mannes
langsam ab nun wartet sie auf eine neue
liebe ja ich bin oft warteliste für die
transplantation wird mit technik
funktioniert und sie schafft das ist die
komplikationen gehört aber das sei
möglich es ist deutlich zu und die
bieterin android setzen die möglichkeit
neue leber krieg zwar dass man von tod
spenden aber geführte ganze leben und
ich bin froh dass das sind die chance
kriegt sie sich nicht selbst endlich vor
dem herrisches trotz der schwere
situation nur positives
diese situation ist wo man so viel
braucht da steht ja fast ein schlechtes
gewissen aber mit level ist mir wichtig
und ich meine jetzt würden jemand sagen
an allen titeln ins präsentation
erstellt es ist schade für das geld weil
ich halt hin dass machten immer wenn die
situation ist image durch gesund werden
[Musik]
die medizin wird weiterhin forschen
leben retten und leiden lindern und sie
wird auch weiterhin viel kosten und klar
wir müssen sparen und das wäre
eigentlich ganz einfach nehmen dort
irgendwo asymmetrie fäden der dass jeder
sie in berlin sieht leistet und
schließlich zurück schraubt und ruft aus
konzentriert notwendig und sinnvoll ist
dass hunt es ist nur eine frage ob sich
die ncs advant gewährte muss man nicht
so zeigen dass die scheiben ursache
wieder muss neu entwickeln
[Musik]
doppel
[Applaus]
die medizin lebt von der hoffnung der
menschen dass sie ein längeres leben und
lebensqualität schreibt
auch bei alex haben alle gehofft und
wohl alle von uns hätten ihm ein langes
leben gewünscht
alex ist kurz vor seinem sechsten
geburtstag gestorben
[Musik]